Shure:  土豆
Shure: Potatoes.
Katrina:  土豆侠吃土
Katrina: Potato hero eats dirt.
Lucia: 这还有一个
Lucia: There's another one here.
Shure:  以塔塔ki马斯
Shure: Itadakimasu.
Alice: 他够不到
Alice: He can't reach it.
Alice: 我们挪一下啊
Alice: Let's move it a bit.
Alice: 那边还有一个
Alice: There's another one over there.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure:  我靠 6张披萨
Shure: Whoa, six pizzas.
Tasha: 天不是吧
Tasha: No way, really?
Lucia: 哎哎为什么会是6个披萨呢
Lucia: Hey, hey, why are there six pizzas?
Jake: 买2赠2啊
Jake: Buy 2, get 2 free.
Tasha: 买3赠3
Tasha: Buy 3, get 3 free.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah
Alice: 啊现在有那个活动
Alice: Ah, there's that event now.
Lucia: 但我们不是买了
Lucia: But didn't we buy it?
Lucia: 就是我还以为是我们买4个
Lucia: I thought we bought four of them.
Lucia: 其中有两个是送的呢
Lucia: And two of them were free gifts.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice: 不行
Alice: No way.
Alice: 我想在这
Alice: I want it here.
Katrina:  从未打过这么富裕的仗
Katrina: I've never fought such a rich battle.
Katrina:  这么多箱子
Katrina: So many boxes.
Alice:笑死
Jake: 对流水席
Jake: Yeah, it's a feast.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Katrina:  哦对
Katrina: Oh right.
Katrina:  可以站在这边站着吃吧
Katrina: We can stand here and eat, right?
Jake: 站着吃吧
Jake: Let's stand and eat.
Jake: 要不就
Jake: Or...
Katrina:  行啊
Katrina: Sure.
Shure:  要不我们什么击鼓传花停哪就
Shure: Or we can play the game where we pass the flower, and whoever it stops at...
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Shure:  哈哈哈就吃哪啊
Shure: Hahaha, they eat there.
Jake: 那你把你的音箱拿上来
Jake: Then bring your speaker up here.
Katrina:  没有
Katrina: I don't have one.
Jake: 手套可以
Jake: Gloves are fine.
Alice:谢谢
Shure:  没开是吗
Shure: It's not on, right?
Katrina:  我说开了
Katrina: I said it's on.
Katrina:  我看有多少电量
Katrina: I'll check the battery.
Katrina:  要不要充一会
Katrina: Should we charge it for a bit?
Tasha: 嗯谢谢
Tasha: Hmm, thanks.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina:  我亮了吗
Katrina: Am I lit up?
Shure:  你亮着
Shure: You're lit.
Katrina:  他怎么肯定
Katrina: How can he be sure?
Katrina:  还挺吓我一跳我们遛一下
Katrina: It really scared me, let's go for a walk.
Lucia: 三个多余的哈哈哈
Lucia: Three extra ones, hahaha.
Alice: 可以开始了吗
Alice: Can we start?
Lucia: 可以尝尝
Lucia: Can we try it?
Jake: 我先吃也行
Jake: I can eat first, it's fine.
Jake: 问题不大问题不大问题不大
Jake: No problem, no problem, no problem.
Alice: 谢谢
Jake: 一切都充满着变化
Jake: Everything is full of change.
Jake: 哈哈哈问题不大
Jake: Hahaha, no problem.
Tasha: 早知道点两个榴莲了
Tasha: If I had known, I would've ordered two durians.
Jake: 子涵喝水
Jake: Zihan, drink some water.
Jake: 你喝哪一个
Jake: Which one are you drinking?
Jake: 几号
Jake: Which number?
Katrina:  今天是什么活动
Katrina: What's the event today?
Katrina:  这个怎么会有6个
Katrina: Why are there six of these?
Katrina:  买4赠2
Katrina: Buy 4, get 2 free.
Shure:  买一赠一
Shure: Buy one, get one free.
Tasha: 买3赠3
Tasha: Buy 3, get 3 free.
Alice:恩
Tasha: 我刚才想买4个的话是会不会不够
Tasha: I was wondering if buying 4 would be enough.
Tasha: 他这是九寸的
Tasha: This is a nine-inch one.
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
Katrina:  连晚饭都解决了
Katrina: It even covers dinner.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Sure.
Jake: 啊也好
Jake: Ah, that works too.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Mm.
Shure:  一会自己操作一下
Shure: You'll need to do it yourself later.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Mm.
Shure:  嗯呐嗯呐
Shure: Yeah, yeah.
Shure:  来吧
Shure: Come on.
Jake: 嗯这边都是什么管家代取了
Jake: Mm, so everything here is handled by the housekeeper.
Jake: 就是请我
Jake: They just invite me.
Jake: 我让他们取一下吧
Jake: I'll let them pick it up.
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Hey.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Mm.
Jake: 那我告诉你号码还是什么呀
Jake: Should I give you the number or what?
Alice: 给你拿
Alice: 要榴莲的吗
Alice: Do you want durian?
Jake: 53愈合期
Jake: 53, recovery period.
Jake: 53还是您
Jake: 53, or you.
Jake: 您要什么呀
Jake: What do you want?
Katrina:  喝了咖啡
Katrina: Had coffee.
Jake: 打电话吧
Jake: Give them a call.
Katrina:  你的食欲会下降
Katrina: Your appetite will decrease.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Mm.
Jake: 好就是我们其实3031栋
Jake: Okay, so we're actually in building 3031.
Jake: 玉河区31栋
Jake: Yuhu District, Building 31.
Jake: 玉河区31 啊
Jake: Yuhu District, 31, ah.
Jake: 玉河区31
Jake: Yuhu District, 31.
Jake: 佑佑的院子
Jake: Youyou's courtyard.
Jake: 啊可以可以对
Jake: Ah, yes, yes, that’s right.
Jake: 嗯好嘞好嘞谢谢
Jake: Hmm, okay, okay, thanks.
Shure:  感觉吃了一半就已经饱了
Shure: I feel full after eating just half.
Tasha: 吃了两片
Tasha: I ate two slices.
Katrina:  带出去野餐吧
Katrina: Let’s take it out for a picnic.
Tasha: 嗯带出去野餐吧
Tasha: Yeah, let’s take it out for a picnic.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Katrina:  走累了搞搞个那野餐
Katrina: After a tiring walk, we’ll have a picnic.
Katrina:  那一坐就开始吃
Katrina: Once we sit down, we start eating.
Katrina:  吃完又走
Katrina: After eating, we walk again.
Jake: 吃不完带走
Jake: If we can’t finish it, we’ll take it away.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Tasha: 再去采风是吧
Tasha: And then we go take some photos, right?
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Yeah, yeah.
Jake: 这个应该可以吃完
Jake: We should be able to finish this.
Tasha: 应该可以吃完
Tasha: We should be able to finish this.
Jake: 不是就是今天的时候
Jake: I mean today, though.
Jake: 嗯不会像之前一样丢掉
Jake: It won’t be like before when we wasted it.
Jake: 丢到第二天就没有用了
Jake: Throwing it away the next day, it becomes useless.
Shure:  煤气高钙
Shure: High-calcium gas.
Shure:  不能浪费食物
Shure: We can’t waste food.
Alice:谢谢
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice:碎了吧唧的
Shure:  看我昨天还看的那个梗
Shure: Look at this joke I saw yesterday.
Shure:  然后就是绑着他强制喂他吃榴莲披萨
Shure: Tying him up and force-feeding him durian pizza. 社会问题
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我还以为是
Lucia: I thought it was...
Lucia: 夏威夷披萨呢
Lucia: Hawaiian pizza.
Shure:  差不多
Shure: Almost.
Tasha: 榴莲披萨
Tasha: Durian pizza.
Tasha: 这么好吃
Tasha: So delicious.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 就是意大利人看到给披萨上放水果
Lucia: Italians would be devastated to see fruit on pizza.
Lucia: 会非常的崩溃
Lucia: They'd be so upset.
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Really?
Shure:  咱们饺子里面放水果给你吃一样
Shure: It’s like putting fruit in dumplings for us.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 他们传统披萨上面是不放水果的
Lucia: Traditionally, they don’t put fruit on pizza.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Shure:  肉夹馍突然给你加了一个番茄酱
Shure: Suddenly added ketchup to the meat sandwich.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 没关系我觉得番茄酱蘸什么都好吃
Tasha: It's okay, I think ketchup tastes good with anything.
Lucia: 肉夹馍为什么要放番茄酱
Lucia: Why would you put ketchup on a meat sandwich?
Tasha: 丰富口感吧
Tasha: To enhance the flavor, I guess.
Lucia: 异端
Lucia: Heresy.
Jake: 臊子面放cheese
Jake: Put cheese on the minced meat noodles.
Lucia: 臊子面放cheese
Lucia: Cheese on minced meat noodles.
Lucia: 但这我怎么觉得还好
Lucia: But that seems okay to me.
Lucia: 还可以接受
Lucia: I can accept that.
Tasha: 我也可以接受
Tasha: I can accept it too.
Jake: 臊子面放cheese
Jake: Cheese on minced meat noodles.
Lucia: 还有美国的那种做成甜了的披萨
Lucia: And those sweet pizzas from America.
Lucia: 好像意大利人也会觉得很崩溃
Lucia: Italians probably find them very frustrating.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 今天还有布朗尼披萨吗
Tasha: Do we still have brownie pizza today?
Lucia: 你猜吧哦买噶
Lucia: Guess what, oh my god.
Jake: 今晚做一个
Jake: Let's make one tonight.
Tasha: 啊我说达美乐的时候啊
Tasha: Oh, I meant from Domino's.
Jake: 真他有啊
Jake: They really have it.
Tasha: 他有啊
Tasha: They have it.
Lucia: 他有
Lucia: They have it.
Jake: 他真的有
Jake: They really have it.
Lucia: 达美乐有这个味
Lucia: Domino's has that flavor.
Tasha: 布朗尼的
Tasha: Brownie.
Tasha: 还有各种各样甜的披萨
Tasha: And all kinds of sweet pizzas.
Tasha: 吃榴莲吗
Tasha: Do you eat durian?
Jake: 吃吃吃草本草本谢谢您
Jake: Eat, eat, eat, herbal, herbal, thank you.
Shure:  你好像触发了什么
Shure: You seem to have triggered something.
Shure:  NPC对话
Shure: An NPC dialogue.
Jake: 去去去
Jake: Go, go, go.
Shure:  稍等稍等
Shure: Wait, wait.
Lucia: 谢谢你
Lucia: Thank you.
Shure:  哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Jake: 因为
Jake: Because.
Tasha: 他是那天唯一一个点那个榴莲汉堡的
Tasha: He was the only one who ordered that durian burger that day.
Tasha: 跟我一起
Tasha: With me.
Jake: 一些珍贵的人类吃披萨镜头
Jake: Some precious footage of people eating pizza.
Lucia: 我
Lucia: I
Lucia: 眼镜怎么这两天又开始疯狂的往下滑
Lucia: Why are my glasses slipping down so much these past couple of days?
Jake: 这两天瘦了
Jake: You lost weight these past couple of days.
Shure:  真的吗
Shure: Really?
Lucia: 不能吧
Lucia: Can't be.
Shure:  这都吃瘦了
Shure: All this eating made you lose weight.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 吃瘦了
Jake: Eating made you lose weight.
Jake: 太辛苦了
Jake: It's too hard.
Jake: 剧组太辛苦了
Jake: The crew is working too hard.
Shure:  天哪
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure:  我们这剧组
Shure: Our crew.
Jake: 把人这两天把人吃瘦了
Jake: Made people lose weight in just a couple of days.
Lucia: 哈哈不至于吧
Lucia: Haha, can't be that bad.
Shure:  供吃供住
Shure: Providing food and housing.
Tasha: 能不瘦吗哈哈哈
Tasha: How can you not lose weight? Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈啊
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure:  我们
Shure: We.
Jake: 这个有问题
Jake: There's a problem with this.
Tasha: 你看
Tasha: Look.
Jake: 我记一下
Jake: I'll note it down.
Tasha: 大家只能挤着一起吃披萨
Tasha: Everyone has to squeeze together to eat pizza.
Tasha: 而不是一个人娱乐
Tasha: Instead of enjoying it alone.
Shure:  就是
Shure: Exactly.
Tasha: 就已经已经遭受不公平的待遇了
Tasha: We've already suffered unfair treatment.
Jake: 不是就
Jake: No, just.
Shure:  这段数据要删掉
Shure: This segment needs to be deleted.
Jake: 对啊
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 小心小心你这个
Jake: Be careful, be careful with this.
Jake: 增加我们很多工作量啊
Jake: It adds a lot to our workload.
Shure:  对不起对不起
Shure: Sorry, sorry.
Jake: 我要记一下
Jake: I'll note it down.
Lucia: 啊什么要删掉
Lucia: Ah, what needs to be deleted?
Lucia: 吃披萨吗
Lucia: Eating pizza?
Shure:  不是
Shure: No.
Tasha: 12.09
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Tasha: 受了不公平的待遇
Tasha: Suffered unfair treatment.
Shure:  你看你又说了一遍
Shure: See, you said it again.
Shure:  他又在说
Shure: He's saying it again
Shure:  逼逼一句
Shure: Blabbering again
Jake: 没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay
Jake: 就这这逼逼逼逼逼的
Jake: Just blabbering like this
Jake: 你们继续吃你们的
Jake: You guys keep eating
Jake: 但是边吃边逼逼逼
Jake: But keep blabbering while eating
Lucia: 那
Lucia: So
Lucia: 我们之前出现了多少要被道德词汇
Lucia: How many moral terms have we encountered before?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: F word的是不是也要
Lucia: Does the F word also
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Katrina:  昨天还看到直升机了
Katrina: We saw a helicopter yesterday
Shure:  啊对
Shure: Oh, right
Katrina:  军用的
Katrina: A military one
Lucia: 对军用的是不是会侵占他的版权啊
Lucia: Wouldn't a military one infringe on his copyright?
Shure:  看一眼
Shure: Take a look
Tasha: 我们昨天放的电影
Tasha: The movie we played yesterday
Tasha: 要不要删掉
Tasha: Should we delete it?
Lucia: 我忘了
Lucia: I forgot
Shure:  咱们昨天吃火锅没戴眼镜
Shure: We ate hotpot yesterday without wearing glasses
Katrina:  哦空调遥控器呢
Katrina: Oh, where's the air conditioner remote?
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Yeah
Katrina:  不想看来着
Katrina: Didn't want to look at it
Alice: 呵呵
Alice: Hehe
Jake: 没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay
Katrina:  薇薇
Katrina: Tasha
Katrina:  昨天那个空调遥控器是不是在你那
Katrina: Did you have the air conditioner remote yesterday?
Katrina:  薇薇嗯遥控器
Katrina: Tasha, yeah, the remote
Tasha: 不在我那
Tasha: It's not with me
Tasha: 我说放在外面的桌上了
Tasha: I said I put it on the table outside
Shure:  空调遥控器
Shure: Air conditioner remote
Katrina:  2楼不通风有点热
Katrina: The second floor isn't ventilated, it's a bit hot
Katrina:  在这里
Katrina: It's here
Lucia: 这俩是同一个味吗
Lucia: Do these two taste the same?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah
Tasha: 可能你加了之后
Tasha: Maybe after you added it
Tasha: 我又不小心又加了一遍
Tasha: I accidentally added it again.
Lucia: 不不不
Lucia: No no no.
Lucia: 有哪位宝宝需要餐巾纸吗
Lucia: Does anyone need napkins?
Tasha: 呃
Tasha: Uh.
Lucia: 需要吗
Lucia: Do you need it?
Tasha: 等一下就需要
Tasha: I'll need it in a bit.
Lucia: 那我先放在你这里
Lucia: I'll put it here for you.
Tasha: 哦我这怎么了
Tasha: Oh, what's up with me?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure:  哦不
Shure: Oh no.
Alice: 下雪了
Alice: It's snowing.
Tasha: 大家够用吗
Tasha: Does everyone have enough?
Lucia: 要
Lucia: Yes.
Jake: 谢谢谢谢
Jake: Thank you, thank you.
Shure:  张万森下雪了
Shure: Zhang Wansen, it's snowing.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Katrina:  我再来一张吧
Katrina: I'll take another one.
Lucia: 如果谁需要纸可以传递一下
Lucia: If anyone needs a napkin, pass it around.
Shure:  是带那个
Shure: Is it the one with...
Shure:  洗洁精的湿巾是吗
Shure: Dish soap wipes, right?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Shure:  哈哈我擦擦
Shure: Haha, let me wipe.
Alice: 恩，哈哈你擦嘴了
Shure:  怎么感觉味不对
Shure: Why does it smell off?
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈再舔起泡了
Katrina: Hahaha, it foams up when licked.
Alice: 那个厨房湿巾
Alice: That's the kitchen wipe.
Alice: 他擦嘴了
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Alice: 一个宝贵的数据
Alice: A precious piece of data.
Shure:  哎我记得我刚才掉了一块肉在这
Shure: Hey, I remember I dropped a piece of meat here.
Shure:  怎么找不到了
Shure: Why can't I find it?
Jake: 掉什么了
Jake: Dropped what?
Jake: 掉披萨了啊
Jake: Dropped pizza?
Shure:  啊不是那个有一块
Shure: No, it was a piece of meat.
Shure:  刚才掉了一块肉
Shure: I just dropped a piece of meat.
Shure:  我记得掉地下了
Shure: I remember it fell to the ground.
Shure:  掉下找不到了
Shure: It fell and I can't find it.
Shure:  行了留给蟑螂先生了
Shure: Fine, it's left for Mr. Cockroach.
Lucia: 为什么你们
Lucia: Why do you guys...
Tasha: 每个盘都送的好均匀啊
Tasha: Every plate is evenly distributed.
Shure:  一两个两个两个
Shure: One or two, two, two.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This...
Katrina:  他俩不是一个
Katrina: They're not the same.
Alice: 所以这个是
Alice: So this is...
Katrina:  我要问一下他是讲新课还是讲复习课
Katrina: I need to ask if he's teaching a new lesson or a review.
Katrina:  这个得等他回来才知道
Katrina: We'll have to wait for him to come back to know.
Tasha: 要不要把整盒整盒
Tasha: Should we put the whole boxes together?
Jake: 好啊拼一拼
Jake: Yeah, let's combine them.
Alice: 这俩可以直接拼过来了
Tasha: 把这个拼在一起
Tasha: Put this together.
Alice:恩，对
Tasha: 对这好像就差两块
Tasha: Yeah, this one is only missing two pieces.
Alice: 一家子一家子
Alice: All in the family, all in the family.
Jake: 这就是什么什么
Jake: This is like... something, something.
Jake: 油泼面拌臊子面
Jake: Oil-splashed noodles mixed with minced meat noodles.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia: 必胜客经典二合一
Lucia: Pizza Hut classic two-in-one.
Jake: 这二合一确实很好
Jake: This two-in-one is really good.
Lucia: 不行我现在站不起来了哈哈
Lucia: No, I can't stand up right now, haha.
Lucia: 啊谢谢谢谢好了
Lucia: Ah, thank you, thank you. All good.
Jake: 嗯挺好
Jake: Hmm, pretty good.
Tasha: 还好把榴莲的都吃完了
Tasha: It's good we finished all the durian.
Tasha: 不然他会污染别的味道
Tasha: Otherwise, it would contaminate the other flavors.
Lucia: 好热好热
Lucia: So hot, so hot.
Jake: 榴莲还是可以吃完的怎么了
Jake: Durian is still edible, what's the matter?
Jake: 哦好热
Jake: Oh, so hot.
Lucia: 可能是二楼没有那么透气的
Lucia: Maybe the second floor isn't so ventilated.
Lucia: 稍等一下啊
Lucia: Hold on a second.
Lucia: 对只有只有卧室的窗户好像能打开
Lucia: Yeah, it seems only the bedroom window can be opened.
Lucia: 大厅的都打不开
Lucia: The living room ones can't be opened.
Alice: 想用一下
Alice: Want to use it?
Jake: 好收溜
Jake: Okay, sure.
Jake: 收丢上礼物上链接
Jake: Collect the gifts, add the links.
Lucia: 这俩叠一块吧
Lucia: Let's stack these two together.
Shure:  这个改过的
Shure: This one has been modified.
Shure:  结构大概是这个样子
Shure: The structure is roughly like this.
Lucia: 我们的垃圾袋啊在那边
Lucia: Our trash bags are over there.
Lucia: good
Lucia: Good.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Katrina:  good
Katrina: Good
Lucia: 等等我
Lucia: Wait for me
Lucia: 好像已经好几天没有打卡
Lucia: I think it's been a few days since I checked in
Lucia: 我的duolingo了
Lucia: On my Duolingo
Jake: 学学什么呢
Jake: What are you learning?
Lucia: 德语
Lucia: German
Jake: 德语
Jake: German
Jake: 学德语干啥
Jake: Why are you learning German?
Lucia: 比较喜欢哦
Lucia: I just like it
Shure:  想带上我的一切
Shure: I want to take everything with me
Shure:  然后
Shure: And then
Alice:洗下手
Shure:  这是水是吧
Shure: This is water, right?
Shure:  20
Shure: 20
Shure:  不能
Shure: Can't
Alice: 还有纸吗
Alice: Is there any paper left?
Shure:  逼着我喝水
Shure: Forcing me to drink water
Alice: 啊谢谢
Alice: Ah, thanks
Alice: 我上个厕所
Alice: I need to use the restroom
Jake: 这个空了
Jake: This one's empty
Alice: 眼镜
Alice: Glasses
Jake: duo lin go是不是你很久没上
Jake: If you don't use Duolingo for a long time
Jake: 他就会把图标变得很丑
Jake: The icon becomes ugly
Lucia: 呃对
Lucia: Uh, yes
Jake: 就是就真的会很就变
Jake: Like, does it really change?
Jake: 会变吗你变了吗
Jake: Did yours change?
Lucia: 会变
Lucia: It changes
Lucia: 就是如果说你好好久不去上课的话
Lucia: If you don't go to class for a long time
Lucia: 他就会变成要么在睡觉的表情
Lucia: It either shows a sleepy expression
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Lucia: 要么就变成沙漠里的一个鸟骷髅
Lucia: Or it becomes a bird skeleton in the desert
Jake: OK
Lucia: 然后如果你每天打卡的话
Lucia: And if you check in every day
Lucia: 他就会非常开心
Lucia: The expression is really happy
Lucia: 那个表情
Lucia: The icon
Lucia: 如果你某一天当天没有打卡
Lucia: If you miss a day
Lucia: 他就会就是呈现一个怒火的表情哦
Lucia: It shows an angry expression, really interesting
Lucia: 真的很有意思
Lucia: It's really fun
Jake: 是
Jake: Yes
Lucia: 我觉得我最大的乐趣不来自于学语言
Lucia: I think my biggest joy doesn't come from learning the language
Lucia: 来自于观赏他
Lucia: Came from watching him
Lucia: 这个图标射程
Lucia: This icon's range
Jake: 可以
Jake: Okay
Jake: 嗯管家什么时候
Jake: Hmm, when's the butler
Jake: 我也不知道管家什么时候
Jake: I don't know when the butler
Jake: 问话要
Jake: Questions should be asked
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Shure:  这个是运动会
Shure: This is the sports meet
Jake: 大伙看看自己眼镜还有多少电
Jake: Everyone check how much battery your glasses have left
Jake: 要不要插充电宝
Jake: Do you need to plug in a power bank?
Jake: 时间差不多了
Jake: It's almost time
Shure:  一直在挂着尿袋
Shure: Always wearing a urine bag
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Got it
Shure:  我们吃了4个披萨
Shure: We ate 4 pizzas
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Uh-huh
Shure:  7个人4个披萨
Shure: 7 people, 4 pizzas
Lucia: 4624
Lucia: 28 大概每个人吃了三四块的样子
Lucia: 28, roughly three to four slices each
Lucia: 为什么要算
Lucia: Why are we calculating this?
Lucia: 条件反射的算一下
Lucia: Reflexively calculated it
Lucia: 估算一下大家的饭量以后好点
Lucia: Estimate everyone's appetite for next time
Shure:  之前还看过一个披萨笑话是
Shure: I once heard a pizza joke
Shure:  说披萨是最诚实的食物
Shure: It said pizza is the most honest food
Shure:  因为他没有欺骗
Shure: Because it doesn't deceive
Lucia: 哦哦OK
Lucia: Oh, okay
Alice:啊，不会叠
Lucia: 对不会
Lucia: Yeah, no
Lucia: 天呐谐音梗扣分哈哈哈
Lucia: Oh my god, puns, points deducted, hahaha
Lucia: 没有反应过来
Lucia: Didn't get it at first
Lucia: 这个我们要放冰箱或者怎么样吗
Lucia: Should we put this in the fridge or what?
Lucia: 还是就在外面放着就行
Lucia: Or just leave it out?
Lucia: 如果一会就用来picknick了
Lucia: If we're using it for a picnic soon
Shure:  先不用放冰箱了
Shure: No need to refrigerate it
Alice: 不用放了下午不就拿走了
Alice: No need, we're taking it this afternoon
Shure:  阴凉遮光无光处对
Shure: Keep it in a cool, dark place, yeah
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my god
Lucia: 嗯好再打一下我们又可以吃了
Lucia: Okay, heat it up and we can eat again
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha: 我就是搜的一模一样他要我106块4
Tasha: I found the exact same one, and it's 106.4 yuan
Alice: 这个是多出来的
Alice: This is extra
Alice: 要搁那吗
Alice: Should we put it there?
Tasha: 嗯这两次尝尝价格不一样人家会说吧
Tasha: Hmm, the prices are different for these two samples, won't they say something?
Shure:  是的哈哈哈
Shure: Yes, hahaha.
Tasha: 不知道呀而且跟你刚刚的界面一模一样
Tasha: I don't know, and it looks exactly like your previous screen.
Jake: 子豪我们再看一下充电宝吧
Jake: Nicous, let's check the power bank again.
Jake: 对你你查
Jake: Yes, you check it.
Tasha: 所以要不还是你查吧
Tasha: So, maybe you should check it?
Jake: 再看一下
Jake: Check it again.
Tasha: 我真的已经打开了
Tasha: I really have already opened it.
Shure:  这是重要素材
Shure: This is important material.
Shure:  所以不可丢不可遗失
Shure: So it can't be lost or misplaced.
Shure:  是吧
Shure: Right?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 对他要在下午2点钟之前要 我们查完之后看
Tasha: Yes, he needs it before 2 PM. We'll check and see after that.
Alice: 你们有空调遥控器在房间里吗
Alice: Do you have the air conditioner remote in your room?
Tasha: 安好吗好
Tasha: Install it? Okay, sure.
Tasha: 好好拜拜
Tasha: Okay, bye.
Alice: Lucy
Alice: Lucy.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm?
Alice: 你的那个空调遥控器是在你房间吗
Alice: Is your air conditioner remote in your room?
Lucia: 啊我没注意
Lucia: Ah, I didn't notice.
Lucia: 因为一直没在
Lucia: Because I haven't been there.
Alice: 你的呢
Alice: What about yours?
Shure:  我的不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Shure:  我的还开着呢
Shure: Mine is still on.
Lucia: 你不冷吗
Lucia: Aren't you cold?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure:  他不
Shure: It's not.
Shure:  他是完全自动
Shure: It's fully automatic.
Shure:  就是冷了
Shure: When it gets cold,
Shure:  他会给我吹热风然后温度合适
Shure: it blows warm air at me until the temperature is just right.
Shure:  他不吹风
Shure: It doesn't blow air otherwise.
Alice: 我觉得你像个面团子
Alice: I think you look like a dough ball.
Lucia: interesting
Lucia: Interesting.
Shure:  为什么
Shure: Why?
Alice: 水多加面
Alice: Add more water if it's too dry,
Alice: 面多加水
Alice: Add more flour if it's too wet.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  昨天和麻酱也是
Shure: Yesterday with the sesame paste too,
Shure:  水多加面
Shure: add more water if needed.
Shure:  水多加麻酱
Shure: Add more sesame paste if there's a lot of water.
Shure:  麻酱多加水
Shure: Add more water if there's a lot of sesame paste.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha
Lucia: 怪不得结局过去那么大一碗啊
Lucia: No wonder the final dish was such a big bowl.
Alice: 世界就是巨大的面团
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  肯定都和上
Shure: It all mixes together.
Lucia: 我的东西在京东上找不到怎么办呢
Lucia: What do I do if I can't find my stuff on JD?
Lucia: 淘宝
Lucia: Try Taobao.
Alice: 我都是淘宝
Alice: I always use Taobao.
Lucia: 我怕淘宝他到不了
Lucia: I'm afraid Taobao won't deliver it.
Alice: 到不了我就退了
Alice: If they can't deliver, I just return it.
Lucia: 哈哈有道理啊
Lucia: Haha, makes sense.
Alice: 我一般就是他那种呃
Alice: I usually go for the ones that ship within 24 or 48 hours.
Alice: 48小时24小时之内发货的
Alice: I just buy those.
Alice: 我就买了
Alice: If they don't deliver, I return it.
Alice: 买不到到不了就退了
Alice: If it can't be delivered, I return it.
Lucia: 要不因为我在淘宝上看到了
Lucia: Otherwise, because I saw it on Taobao.
Lucia: 我的那些渔网什么的
Lucia: My fishing nets and stuff.
Lucia: 我觉得还挺合适的
Lucia: I think they're quite suitable.
Lucia: 那我还是淘宝上买算了
Lucia: So I should just buy them on Taobao.
Alice: 呃
Alice: Uh.
Lucia: 这是用来装饰房间的
Lucia: These are for decorating the room.
Alice: 装饰房间的
Shure:  渔网
Shure: Fishing nets?
Katrina:  捕梦网是不是
Katrina: You mean dreamcatchers?
Lucia: 哦没有就是
Lucia: Oh no, it's just...
Lucia: 是对但是跟海有关
Lucia: Yeah, but related to the sea.
Lucia: 就我想的是
Lucia: So I was thinking...
Lucia: 可能做成地中海风格的那种
Lucia: Maybe making a Mediterranean style.
Lucia: 蓝白的颜色
Lucia: Blue and white colors.
Lucia: 但我发现我现在买的材料都是白的
Lucia: But I found all the materials I bought are white.
Lucia: 还没有蓝材料呢
Lucia: There's no blue material yet.
Alice: 如果你想做地中海风格
Alice: If you want Mediterranean style...
Alice: 我可以把高中的老师捐给你
Alice: I can donate my high school teacher to you.
Lucia: 把高中老师捐给我
Lucia: Donate your high school teacher to me?
Lucia: 为什么
Lucia: Why?
Alice: 因为他是个地中海啊
Alice: Because he's bald (like the Mediterranean Sea)!
Lucia: 啊OK好
Lucia: Ah, okay, got it.
Jake: 那我再说
Jake: Then let me say this...
Jake: 你还有电吗
Jake: Do you still have power?
Alice: 露西呀你还有电吗
Alice: Lucia, do you still have power?
Lucia: 嗯你在问我吗
Lucia: Hmm, are you asking me?
Jake: 没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Tasha: 这个在录着呢
Tasha: This is recording.
Jake: 你你你插掉
Jake: You, you, you unplug it.
Tasha: 直接插掉就行吗
Tasha: Just unplug it directly?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 还有60%
Tasha: It's at 60%.
Jake: 嗯行可以
Jake: Hmm, okay, that works.
Shure:  你看那个磁吸压到头发了
Shure: Look, that magnet is crushing the hair.
Lucia: 我打算把那个串珠还是买一串
Lucia: I'm planning to buy another string of those beads.
Lucia: 好吧如果他来得及到
Lucia: Okay, if he can get it in time.
Lucia: 咱可能还能做一下那个水母灯
Lucia: Maybe we can still make that jellyfish lamp.
Lucia: 再来点欧根纱
Lucia: And get some organza.
Alice: 我本来昨天想买的
Alice: I was planning to buy it yesterday.
Alice: 然后发现跟我的啊
Alice: Then I realized with my...
Lucia: 啊我打算买一米的蓝色欧根纱
Lucia: Ah, I'm planning to buy a meter of blue organza.
Lucia: 我可以在房间里面弄一下
Lucia: I can do something with it in the room.
Lucia: 然后剩下的就你如如果就算真的要做灯
Lucia: And the rest, if we do end up making the lamp,
Lucia: 它里面用的纱也很少
Lucia: It uses very little organza inside.
Lucia: 就我们每个人可以弄一块
Lucia: So each of us can take a piece.
Lucia: 然后放在里面
Lucia: And put it inside.
Alice: 然后给他剪掉
Alice: Then cut it off.
Lucia: 对对就比较好看一些
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, it looks nicer that way.
Alice: 边角料可以旋转一下固定一下
Alice: The scraps can be twisted and fixed.
Alice: 然后贴贴
Alice: Then stick them.
Alice: 贴在什么地方
Alice: Stick them somewhere.
Lucia: 对的
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 我觉得你昨天安利给我的那个桌布
Lucia: I think that tablecloth you recommended to me yesterday,
Lucia: 真的很好看
Lucia: It looks really good.
Alice: 嗯我也我也买桌布了
Alice: Hmm, I bought a tablecloth too.
Jake: 桌布桌布挂墙上
Jake: Tablecloth, tablecloth, hang it on the wall.
Lucia: 不是啦
Lucia: No, no.
Lucia: 桌布当然是放在桌子上
Lucia: A tablecloth is, of course, for the table.
Jake: 你们有桌子吗
Jake: Do you guys have a table?
Alice: 我有一个小的
Alice: I have a small one.
Lucia: 他有小桌子
Lucia: He has a small table.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 四十乘
Alice: Forty by...
Alice:不是，40直径的
Lucia: 我打算配一个塑料的小方桌
Lucia: I'm planning to get a small plastic square table.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 就会能轻一点
Lucia: It will be a bit lighter.
Lucia: 也不是很贵
Lucia: It's not very expensive either.
Lucia: 因为我那个架子实在是太丑了
Lucia: Because that rack of mine is really too ugly.
Jake: 明白
Jake: Got it.
Lucia: 无法改造我觉得
Lucia: I think it's impossible to renovate.
Alice: 我觉得我们这个户型还挺好的
Alice: I think our layout is pretty good.
Alice: 因为比较小就
Alice: Because it's quite small.
Alice:它就显东西
Shure:  往下东西
Shure: Move things down.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey.
Alice: 哎东西呢
Alice: Hey, where are the things?
Jake: 我们也整点喝的吧
Jake: Let's get some drinks too.
Jake: 哈哈给给您倒点咖咖啡给您倒点水
Jake: Haha, let me pour you some coffee, let me pour you some water.
Shure:  谢谢
Shure: Thanks.
Katrina:  这咖啡吗
Katrina: Is this coffee?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina:  这好像昨天晚上调的
Katrina: It seems like it was made last night.
Jake: 就是这个
Jake: Yes, this is the one.
Jake: 这些应该都用过
Jake: All of these should have been used.
Alice:哦，是的
Jake: 来吧我们
Jake: Come on, let's...
Jake: 我们最后一名做到
Jake: Our last person will do it.
Katrina:  我怎么做到老板
Katrina: How do I do it, boss?
Alice: 最后一名
Alice: The last one.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake: 我也不做
Jake: I'm not doing it either.
Jake: 就是呃我们最后一名开始
Jake: It's just, uh, our last person will start.
Jake: 呃介绍自己的礼物然后第一名
Jake: Uh, introduce their gift and then the first place.
Jake: 呃大家秀一轮之后然后第一名开始挑
Jake: Uh, after everyone shows theirs, the first place will start picking.
Jake: 对对对我们排名了
Jake: Yes, yes, we have ranked them.
Jake: 我们有电量96的
Jake: We have a battery level of 96.
Alice: 到1-2
Alice: To 1-2.
Alice: 嗯我在你后边
Alice: Hmm, I'm behind you.
Tasha: 呃我不知道
Tasha: Uh, I don't know.
Tasha: 写了一个东西
Tasha: Wrote something.
Tasha: 乱七八糟的东西
Tasha: A bunch of messy stuff.
Jake: 笑口常开
Jake: Keep smiling.
Tasha: 明信片
Tasha: Postcard.
Shure:  天下粮仓
Shure: Grain warehouse.
Tasha: 种植套餐
Tasha: Planting package
Katrina:  呵呵呵
Katrina: Hehehe
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow
Lucia: 这
Lucia: This
Tasha: 营养塔
Tasha: Nutrition tower
Tasha: 营养土盆栽和培养米种这张卡片的
Tasha: Nutritious soil potted plants and seed cultivation, this card
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Shure:  这鼓好用吗
Shure: Is this drum good?
Katrina:  把这摆着
Katrina: Put this here
Jake: 不要太玩
Jake: Don't play too much
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Alright
Lucia: 你说这个鼓吗
Lucia: You mean this drum?
Katrina:  不是  蛊  虫子下蛊了
Katrina: No, it's "Gu", the insect curse
Lucia: OK OK
Lucia: OK, OK
Shure:  这个怎么翻译成英文
Shure: How do you translate this into English?
Katrina:  100人就开始算塔罗了
Katrina: Once there are 100 people, we start reading Tarot cards
Jake: 这什么呀
Jake: What's this?
Tasha: 营养土啊
Tasha: Nutritious soil
Lucia: 是椰土那种吗
Lucia: Is it coconut soil?
Tasha: 啊啊
Tasha: Yeah, yeah
Jake: 香菇是长
Jake: Mushrooms grow
Jake: 香菇是好
Jake: Mushrooms are good
Tasha: 可以养狼蛛用
Tasha: You can use it to raise tarantulas
Lucia: sorry狼蛛
Lucia: Sorry, tarantulas?
Alice:狼蛛哈哈
Jake: 哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 对就是养狼蛛是要垫椰土的
Lucia: Yeah, to raise tarantulas, you need coconut soil
Alice: 你有这爱好
Alice: You have this hobby?
Lucia: 我现在没养
Lucia: I don't raise them now
Lucia: 我以前养过
Lucia: I used to
Lucia: 但是
Lucia: But
Jake: 你多大呀
Jake: How old are you?
Lucia: 被我养死了哈哈哈
Lucia: I raised them to death, hahaha
Lucia: 呃4只宠物
Lucia: Uh, four pets
Lucia: 那个岂不是狼蛛不舍他们偷吃养的
Lucia: Doesn't that mean the tarantulas won't eat them sneakily?
Jake: 啊倒第二
Jake: Ah, second last
Jake: 倒数第二名
Jake: Second to last
Jake: 第二名吧
Jake: Second place?
Jake: 第二名
Jake: Second place
Alice: 哦
Alice: Oh
Alice: 准备了一个手链
Alice: Prepared a bracelet
Alice: 是帝王沙跟绿松石的哦
Alice: It's made of emperor sand and turquoise.
Alice: 朱砂
Alice: Cinnabar.
Alice: 就是古代皇帝批折子用的那个红色的那个颜料就是从这边提取的
Alice: It's the red pigment that ancient emperors used for their seals, extracted from this.
Alice: 然后绿松石就是蓝绿色
Alice: And turquoise is blue-green.
Alice: 因为有铜跟铁的那些
Alice: Because of the copper and iron...
Alice: 哎不是铜
Alice: Oh, not copper.
Jake: 啥
Jake: What?
Alice: 铜跟
Alice: Copper and...
Shure:  朱砂
Shure: Cinnabar.
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice: 铜跟就是铜跟铁
Alice: Copper and tin, copper and iron.
Alice: 然后他这个会呈现不同的颜色
Alice: Then it shows different colors.
Alice: 主要是我觉得朱砂比较辟邪
Alice: Mainly, I think cinnabar wards off evil.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice: 是这样
Alice: That's it.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 谁电量多来着啊
Jake: Who has the most battery left?
Shure:  啊我我我最老
Shure: Ah, me, me, I'm the oldest.
Jake: 你多少来着
Jake: How much do you have?
Shure:  我是十几
Shure: I'm at ten something.
Shure:  好像
Shure: I think.
Jake: 挺好哎
Jake: That's good.
Jake: 你这啥玩意
Jake: What is this thing?
Shure:  这个是一个乐器
Shure: This is a musical instrument.
Shure:  它是一个叫做沙球的乐器
Shure: It's called a shaker.
Tasha: 原来这个放到这一直就是你的呀
Tasha: So it's been yours all along?
Katrina:  哈哈哈已经被玩过了
Katrina: Hahaha, it's been played with already.
Shure:  已经被大家玩坏了
Shure: It's already been played to death.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  然后他可以这个样子
Shure: And then you can do this.
Tasha: 然后呢
Tasha: And then?
Shure:  这是他的沙球作用
Shure: This is its shaker function.
Shure:  然后他还可以
Shure: And it can also...
Shure:  就是比如说
Shure: For example...
Shure:  就是它会发出一些碰撞的声音
Shure: It makes some collision sounds.
Shure:  对然后
Shure: Yeah, and then...
Tasha: AMSR啊哈哈
Tasha: ASMR, haha.
Shure:  最最最酷炫的就是它可以摆起来
Shure: The coolest part is that it can stand up.
Tasha: 好酷哈哈
Tasha: So cool, haha.
Shure:  然后配合摆动
Shure: And sway with the rhythm.
Shure:  再加上一些
Shure: Add a bit more.
Katrina:  摇滚的东西
Katrina: Rock elements.
Shure:  一些一点点魔法
Shure: And a little bit of magic.
Shure:  然后就可以打出不一样的节奏型
Shure: Then you can create a different rhythm.
Shure:  就比如说像这个样子
Shure: For example, like this.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake: 来一段
Jake: Give us a piece.
Shure:  这是来一段
Shure: Here it goes.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake: 我以为你叫什么大大节了
Jake: I thought you were going to play something big.
Lucia: 不应该来点这个才艺表演吗
Lucia: Shouldn't we have some kind of performance?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure:  竹板这么一打呀
Shure: When the bamboo clappers hit,
Shure:  别的咱不夸
Shure: We don't brag about anything else,
Shure:  咱就夸夸咱那个狗不理包子
Shure: We just brag about our Goubuli buns.
Shure:  哈哈这一种赛博快板吧
Shure: Haha, this is a kind of cyber clapper talk.
Shure:  可能非洲人的快板就是长这个样子
Shure: Maybe African clapper talk looks like this.
Shure:  这确实好像是一种非洲的乐器
Shure: Haha, this really seems like an African instrument.
Alice:哈哈哈
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Shure:  他的学名我忘了叫啥了
Shure: I forgot its scientific name.
Shure:  反正大家都叫它砂锤啊砂球
Shure: Anyway, people call it a shaker or maraca.
Shure:  然后这是一个静音的
Shure: This one's a silent type.
Shure:  就是它就是这种橡木的
Shure: It's made of oak.
Shure:  然后正常可能会有那种金属的
Shure: Usually, you might see ones made of metal.
Shure:  或者塑料的
Shure: Or plastic.
Shure:  就是音色是不一样的
Shure: They each have a different sound.
Shure:  这个就比较不那么吵
Shure: This one's less noisy.
Shure:  然后声音也稍微暖一些
Shure: And the sound is a bit warmer.
Shure:  然后送出一个留一个
Shure: I'll give one away and keep one.
Shure:  因为演出还需要用的
Shure: Because I need it for performances.
Shure:  哈哈哈不能把吃饭家伙事丢了
Shure: Haha, can't lose my livelihood tools.
Jake: 你是什么演出要用
Jake: What kind of performances do you need it for?
Shure:  就一些现场的演出也会用到的
Shure: It's used for some live performances.
Jake: 哈哈就煮饭啊
Jake: Haha, just for cooking?
Shure:  没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  制造一种氛围音的时候
Shure: When creating ambient sounds.
Lucia: 好像ASMR啊
Lucia: Sounds like ASMR.
Shure:  我再配合这手链给你
Shure: I'll combine it with this bracelet.
Katrina:  睡了
Katrina: Fell asleep.
Tasha: 睡了
Tasha: Fell asleep.
Lucia: 困了困了
Lucia: So sleepy, so sleepy.
Alice: 摇酒天赋
Alice: Cocktail shaking talent.
Shure:  嗯好哈哈哈好
Shure: Hmm, alright, hahaha, alright.
Katrina:  然后介绍我的吧
Katrina: Then let me introduce mine.
Katrina:  我就是前前前一段时间去成都玩
Katrina: So, some time ago I went to Chengdu to have fun.
Katrina:  然后去那个玉林路那一些古着店
Katrina: Then I went to those vintage stores on Yulin Road.
Katrina:  淘的一些
Katrina: Got some stuff.
Katrina:  呃就是钥匙扣和胸针
Katrina: Uh, like keychains and brooches.
Shure:  就是淘宝店淘的新东西是吗
Shure: So, you got new stuff from those stores, right?
Shure:  哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Katrina:  对淘就是他他那个开店那个店主
Katrina: Yes, got them. The shop owner.
Katrina:  他们是自己设计的
Katrina: They designed it themselves.
Katrina:  就是自己是一个设计工作室
Katrina: It's their own design studio.
Katrina:  然后就只有在他
Katrina: And only there.
Katrina:  们那里能买到
Katrina: Can you buy it.
Katrina:  然后买的是大熊猫的大熊猫
Katrina: So, I bought a panda, a giant panda.
Katrina:  这是钥匙扣
Katrina: This is a keychain.
Katrina:  这是一个胸针
Katrina: And this is a brooch.
Katrina:  就是一个鸟和一个猫
Katrina: It's a bird and a cat.
Katrina:  我也不知道什么意思
Katrina: I don't know what it means.
Katrina:  我只是觉得很可爱
Katrina: I just thought it was cute.
Katrina:  我就买回来送给大家
Katrina: So I bought them to give to everyone.
Katrina:  好OK
Katrina: Okay, that's it.
Alice: Lucy
Alice: Lucy.
Jake: 好96
Jake: Okay, 96.
Katrina:  嗯抽口的话对这里面有一个marry me
Katrina: Hmm, if I draw a card, there's a "marry me" in it.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Lucia: 不是marry me
Lucia: It's not "marry me".
Lucia: 就是我本来是就是有一个小手做的耳钉
Lucia: I originally had a handmade earring.
Lucia: 然后对这个其实很简单
Lucia: And, yeah, it's actually pretty simple.
Lucia: 就只要买打了孔的珠子
Lucia: You just need to buy drilled beads.
Lucia: 和这个这个耳针
Lucia: And these earring posts.
Lucia: 然后拿热熔胶把它粘在一起就可以
Lucia: Then use hot glue to stick them together.
Lucia: 对然后但是就是我我自己做完之后
Lucia: Yeah, but after I made it.
Lucia: 我觉得这个还那个效果还挺好
Lucia: I thought the effect was pretty good.
Lucia: 所以我做了好几对
Lucia: So I made several pairs.
Lucia: 然后刚好就是这边要给大家
Lucia: And just in time to give to everyone here.
Lucia: 就是给大家准备礼物
Lucia: As gifts for everyone.
Lucia: 我就准备了一个
Lucia: I just prepared one.
Lucia: 感觉是自己的手做的话会比较有意义
Lucia: I feel like it’s more meaningful if I make it myself.
Lucia: 但是为什么我又去买了一个抽屉呢
Lucia: But why did I buy another drawer?
Lucia: 因为我发现这个盒子有点大
Lucia: Because I realized this box is a bit big.
Lucia: 当我把它放到这盒子里面的时候
Lucia: When I put it in this box,
Lucia: 他们俩显得非常的孤单
Lucia: They both looked very lonely.
Lucia: 然后我为了增加开盒的时候的气势
Lucia: So to make the unboxing more impressive,
Lucia: 我就又去买了一个抽壳放在里面
Lucia: I bought another drawer to put inside.
Lucia: 然后但这样一放
Lucia: But by doing this,
Lucia: 就会完全挡住他们两个
Lucia: It completely covered both of them.
Lucia: 所以就是对
Lucia: So, yeah.
Lucia: 于是这个礼物
Lucia: So this gift
Lucia: 就变成了一个复合装饰的样子
Lucia: Became a composite decoration.
Lucia: 然后这个就很就是这个
Lucia: And it turned out quite nice.
Lucia: 我觉得还蛮好看的
Lucia: I think it looks pretty good.
Lucia: 因为它是那种丝绒的料
Lucia: Because it’s made of velvet.
Lucia: 就是穿很多裙子都可以搭配
Lucia: It can match with many dresses.
Lucia: 但是男孩子的话就不考虑了
Lucia: But for boys, just forget about it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure:  行了
Shure: Alright.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Shure:  你怎么能定定义我
Shure: How can you define me like that?
Lucia: 对不起对不起我错了啊
Lucia: I'm sorry, I'm sorry, my bad.
Shure:  我就是你看正好两个嘛
Shure: See, it fits just right.
Alice: 哦
Alice: Oh.
Shure:  是吧
Shure: Right?
Lucia: 没有想到这一次
Lucia: I didn’t expect this time
Lucia: 那那那说明你也是可以试用的
Lucia: That means you can try it too.
Lucia: 那大家挑选起来就没有顾虑
Lucia: Then everyone can choose without worry.
Alice: 顾虑
Shure:  好话都
Shure: You’ve said all the good stuff.
Shure:  让你说完了
Shure: Hahaha
Shure:  哈哈哈
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 那路亚开始
Jake: Now, Luya, start.
Lucia: 这
Lucia: This.
Jake: 这怎么挑的
Jake: How did you pick this?
Lucia: 我以为是盲挑来着
Lucia: I thought it was a blind pick.
Jake: 咱盲挑
Jake: Let’s do a blind pick.
Lucia: 感觉都很有特色的样子
Lucia: They all seem quite unique.
Shure:  先说一句好话
Shure: Say something nice first.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  憋出来了
Katrina: Couldn't hold it in.
Jake: 那咱要不盲挑也可以要不
Jake: So, should we just pick blindly or...
Lucia: 我我我摇个骰子吧
Lucia: I'll, I'll, I'll roll a dice.
Lucia: 那就要不
Lucia: Or should we...
Shure:  行
Shure: Sure.
Lucia: 嗯可以抽到我自己怎么办
Lucia: What if I draw myself?
Katrina:  一二
Katrina: One, two.
Alice: 再来一轮
Alice: Let's do another round.
Katrina:  4
Katrina: Four.
Shure:  1234 对咱们
Shure: One, two, three, four, right?
Lucia: 对咱们
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 咱们的群呢
Lucia: Our group, right?
Lucia: 我放到我就在咱们群里摇好了
Lucia: I'll roll it in our group chat.
Shure:  公平公正公开
Shure: Fair and square.
Shure:  sorry
Shure: Sorry.
Katrina:  特别可爱是不是
Katrina: Isn't it super cute?
Jake: 直播摇骰子
Jake: Live dice rolling.
Lucia: 2 我结果大家能看得到吗
Lucia: Two. Can everyone see the result?
Lucia: 发了一个
Lucia: I posted one.
Tasha: 看到了
Tasha: I see it.
Alice: 二
Alice: Two.
Lucia: 二
Lucia: Two.
Alice: 谁是2
Alice: Who's number two?
Lucia: 按介绍说明
Lucia: Follow the instructions.
Alice: 我是2
Alice: I'm number two.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 谢谢可馨
Lucia: Thank you, Kexin.
Lucia: 啊这个包装也好好看
Lucia: Ah, this packaging looks so nice.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina:  表情里
Katrina: In the expressions.
Jake: 那我们第二
Jake: Now our second...
Jake: 第二名来挑
Jake: Second place to pick.
Jake: 倒数第二名来挑
Jake: Second to last to pick.
Shure:  哈哈你挑的你都都不那什么了
Shure: Haha, you picked, you didn't even...
Shure:  客套话都不说直接闪了
Shure: Didn't even say anything polite, just left.
Katrina:  我
Katrina: I...
Katrina:  哈哈迫不及待啊
Katrina: Haha, couldn't wait.
Katrina:  会直接搜筛子
Katrina: I'll just search for dice.
Jake: 这是真色子 假色子每次都能摇6
Jake: This is a real dice. The fake ones always roll a 6.
Shure:  哎你这是固定三的
Shure: Hey, yours is fixed at 3.
Katrina:  真假
Katrina: Really?
Katrina:  什么叫固定3
Katrina: What do you mean by fixed at 3?
Jake: 那再再忍一下你自己
Jake: Hold on, just bear with it for a bit.
Shure:  一二哎
Shure: One, two, hey.
Shure:  不是3是我  3是我
Shure: It's not 3, it's me. 3 is me.
Jake: 等一下我再再再摇一下看是固定的吗
Jake: Wait a second, let me roll it again to see if it's fixed.
Alice: 不是吧不是
Alice: No, it's not.
Shure:  不是不是
Shure: It's not, it's not.
Jake: OK那那行那行
Jake: OK, that's fine then.
Katrina:  还是3
Katrina: It's still 3.
Lucia: 还是3
Lucia: Still 3.
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Oh man.
Shure:  你没有表这个表情吗
Shure: Don't you have any expression for this?
Katrina:  哦
Katrina: Oh.
Jake: 咬出一个亿
Jake: Roll a billion.
Lucia: 哦咬出一个亿
Lucia: Oh, roll a billion.
Katrina:  给我自己
Katrina: For myself.
Shure:  那就3吧
Shure: Then just go with 3.
Jake: 就三三好
Jake: Yes, 3 is good.
Shure:  唉
Shure: Sigh.
Katrina:  哈哈哈每天晚上你会听到我在房间
Katrina: Haha, every night you'll hear me in my room.
Shure:  没事我在你楼下
Shure: It's fine, I'm downstairs.
Jake: 好那到你摇吧
Jake: Alright, now it's your turn to roll.
Jake: 你倒啊
Jake: Go ahead.
Shure:  我我摇吧还是
Shure: Should I roll it or...
Jake: 你客套话呢
Jake: Are you being polite?
Shure:  客套话就是
Shure: Polite means...
Katrina:  谢谢大家
Katrina: Thank you, everyone.
Shure:  大家每个都非常的棒
Shure: Everyone did a great job.
Shure:  然后呢
Shure: And then...
Shure:  让我实在难以割舍
Shure: It makes it really hard for me to choose.
Shure:  选哪个割舍其他的
Shure: Which one to choose and leave the others.
Shure:  都是一种
Shure: It's all...
Katrina:  演上了
Katrina: Here comes the acting.
Shure:  我是几 四
Shure: What's my number? Four.
Shure:  1234 呀
Shure: One, two, three, four, oh yeah.
Katrina:  呀
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina:  这么可爱的送给你
Katrina: Something this cute is for you.
Shure:  哪有
Shure: Really?
Katrina:  送给你哈哈送给你
Katrina: It's for you, haha, it's for you.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 达成了交换
Lucia: The exchange is complete.
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Nice.
Jake: 那我们
Jake: So we...
Shure:  剩下二位就变成交换了
Shure: The remaining two will exchange.
Alice: 好
Alice: Okay.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Alice: 你得给我
Alice: You need to give it to me.
Alice: 然后他再给你
Alice: Then he will give it to you.
Tasha: 我知道
Tasha: I know.
Alice: 谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Shure:  完了
Shure: Done.
Shure:  没抽到洋鼓很可惜
Shure: It's a pity we didn't draw the foreign drum.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 那就收拾收拾准备出发
Jake: Let's pack up and get ready to leave.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina:  你这个要导数据吗
Katrina: Do you need to export this data?
Jake: 要
Jake: Yes.
Katrina:  你之前要倒一会啊
Katrina: You need to transfer it first.
Tasha: 这钱我也不知道怎么啊
Tasha: I don't know what to do with this money.
Tasha: 就是好看
Tasha: It's just pretty.
Shure:  卡掉
Shure: Card stuck.
Alice:你这个写的好好看，你有那个，练字的那种
Alice: Your handwriting is so beautiful. Do you have calligraphy practice materials?
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice:那种  那种东西吗  可以给我练
Alice: That kind of stuff? Can I use it to practice?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 那个是书法课上面老师
Tasha: That's from the calligraphy class teacher.
Tasha: 呃统一买的
Tasha: Bought uniformly.
Lucia: 哦可以好奇一下写的什么
Lucia: Oh, I'm curious, what did you write?
Alice: 笑口常开
Alice: Always smile.
Lucia: 哇好好看啊
Lucia: Wow, it's beautiful.
Lucia: 写的好好
Lucia: You write so well.
Alice: 回眸
Alice: Turn back.
Jake: 啊谁写的
Jake: Ah, who wrote this?
Jake: 你写的哦
Jake: You wrote it?
Lucia: 微微写的
Lucia: Tasha wrote it.
Jake: 哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Lucia: 好好看
Lucia: Looks great.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Awesome.
Shure:  是不是有点太短了
Shure: Isn't it a bit too short?
Alice:癸卯
Jake: 好看
Jake: Looks good.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 就大家把礼物放到自己房间
Jake: Everyone, put your gifts in your room.
Jake: 然后下去再一起结束就结束了
Jake: Then come down and we'll wrap it up together.
Alice: 癸卯是上一年
Alice: Guǐmǎo was last year.
Alice: 去年冬天写的
Alice: I wrote it last winter.
Tasha: 对哎我
Tasha: Yeah, I...
Jake: 我跳舞了
Jake: I danced.
Alice: 今年是甲辰
Jake: 在外面跳舞回眸
Jake: Dance outside and turn around.
Alice:甲辰  癸卯
Jake: 你们得在外面跳舞
Jake: You guys need to dance outside and turn around.
Jake: 然后拍拍照
Jake: And then take pictures.
Alice: 癸卯  对不起
Alice: Guǐmǎo, sorry.
Alice: 我念对念惯了
Alice: I'm used to reading it like that.
Alice: 癸卯
Alice: Guǐmǎo.
Jake: 对就是pick lick是跳舞对吧
Jake: Yes, pick lick means dance, right?
Jake: 准备好防晒准备好
Jake: Get ready with sunscreen.
Shure:  玩吧
Shure: Let's play.
Jake: 呃拍拍照准备最后一天放PPT准备好
Jake: Uh, take pictures, get ready for the last day's PPT.
Jake: 对就是手机拍拍照
Jake: Yes, take pictures with your phone.
Lucia: 为什么我会砸到我自己的手
Lucia: Why do I keep hitting my own hand?
Shure:  因为它长
Shure: Because it's long.
Shure:  哦不不不就是夹的
Shure: Oh no, it's just pinched.
Jake: 呃对OK
Jake: Uh, right, OK.
Jake: 然后准备买肉
Jake: And get ready to buy some meat.
Lucia: 不行我还是会砸到自己的手
Lucia: No, I still keep hitting my own hand.
Jake: 晚上还有烤串
Jake: There will be BBQ skewers tonight.
Jake: BBQ晚上烤串加甜点
Jake: BBQ skewers and desserts tonight.
Tasha: 下午是要出去吗
Tasha: Are we going out this afternoon?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Is that okay?
Katrina:  晚上还有披萨
Katrina: There's also pizza tonight.
Katrina:  两个够了不用再点
Katrina: Two are enough, no need to order more.
Jake: 这下午茶是披萨
Jake: This afternoon tea is pizza.
Jake: 可能在外边你们走累了吃俩披萨
Jake: Maybe you can have two pizzas if you get tired outside.
Katrina:  哦你说让披萨带出去
Katrina: Oh, you mean to take the pizza outside.
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Is that okay?
Katrina:  可以
Katrina: Yes, it is.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina:  我得换件衣服
Katrina: I need to change my clothes.
Katrina:  我得装这个东西没口袋
Katrina: I need to carry this thing, and it has no pockets.
Katrina:  装裤子
Katrina: Put on some pants.
Shure:  来杨老板坐这
Shure: Come on, Jake, sit here.
Shure:  我给你治愈一下
Shure: I'll heal you a bit.
Shure:  哎呦哎呦
Shure: Oh, oh.
Lucia: 给你听个现场的鲜花
Lucia: Let me play you some live flowers.
Jake: 环绕声是吧
Jake: Surround sound, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  一般拿个颂锅先duang
Shure: Usually, you take a gong and "duang".
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: 还是双声道的
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 挺好水平挺高
Jake: Pretty good, high level.
Jake: 自带混响
Jake: Built-in reverb.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 哈哈这视频可以录吗
Lucia: Haha, can we record this video?
Lucia: 晚上睡觉的时候就用来助眠用
Lucia: Use it to help you sleep at night.
Jake: 可以你这卖钱吗
Jake: Can you sell this?
Jake: 你要不你录一段
Jake: How about you record a segment?
Jake: 卖钱
Jake: And sell it.
Lucia: 你开一个
Lucia: You should start one.
Jake: 卖多少钱
Jake: How much will you sell it for?
Lucia: AMSR频道
Lucia: An ASMR channel.
Jake: 这个卖多少钱
Jake: How much will you sell this for?
Shure:  不知道
Shure: No idea.
Jake: 你这个掉了
Jake: You dropped this.
Shure:  我这个可以摘了
Shure: I can take this off.
Shure:  应该
Shure: I think.
Jake: 行啊
Jake: Alright.
Shure:  是要导数据的是吧
Shure: We need to export the data, right?
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Alice: 现在就导吗
Alice: Export it now?
Jake: 对他们把东西放回房间
Jake: Yeah, they need to put things back in the room.
Jake: 然后把眼镜给解决
Jake: Then take care of the glasses.
Jake: 然后再结束
Jake: Then it's done.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Jake: 放回去
Jake: Put it back.
Jake: 然后再结束
Jake: Then finish it.
Jake: 再都
Jake: And then all
Shure:  忘拿了
Shure: Forgot to take it.
Shure:  差点
Shure: Almost.
Jake: 不是放回去到下面一起结束这么回事
Jake: It's not about putting it back and finishing it together below.
Shure:  好OK
Shure: Okay, got it.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Jake: 子堂开工
Jake: Starting now.
Alice: 这开的真好
Alice:你看这是你的吗
Alice: Look, is this yours?
Katrina:  是我的
Katrina: It's mine.
Jake: 呃停OK
Jake: Uh, stop. Okay.
Alice: 停掉了
Alice: It's stopped.
Jake: 哎让他等我们倒吧
Jake: Hey, let him wait for us to finish.
Alice: done
Alice: Done.